when you're the master of this film as
the director and the lead actor who's
the first person you want to show the
film to and get their opinion that
matters to you well that's an
interesting question nothing I've ever
been asked that question before
oh yeah a real stump now I wanted to I
had always had to go and watch a film
alone you know I just did you know sort
of a personal thing and you know there's
a lot of expectation and worry about how
the film itself turned out how your work
turns out everything else but recently
I've been taking my girlfriend with me
so I suppose my girlfriend the first
time she's asked um yeah she is yes
you know she was honest she's honest but
she's also honest through that sort of
prism like your mom would be like
everything you do is I love so you know
it's not it's not like it's not like
it's a you know a film critic going to
see it I think you need someone on my
side yourself um I have to tell you oh
yeah well because you spend that much
time with an actor and you know he's the
central role I remember the first time I
showed you and I was a bit nervous about
our whole performance but also because
it was premature yeah and it's how I
showed he was quite you know about three
and a half hours long and you know
you're sitting there going oh is he
going to get it is he not going to get
it I'd I don't I suppose you know
otherwise just be a very awkward
position that we'd be sitting next to
one another of you if he's not going to
get it yeah um so I suppose probably
Charlie er well and you know what so
great about is the fact that King Arthur
is able to pull a sword out of the rock
I mean he has a rights to that but do
you have any hidden talents or tricks
I can't believe mine I could own
okay watch it's kind of gross okay ready
Wow right yeah that's that's pretty wel
all right Wow
oh my all right move on not bad they go
yeah yeah that's really good and
yourself anything no no
oh I'm not be really cool I really don't
I feel quite an adequate now try this
because it's really yeah I'm a huge fan
of your films because you have this
trademark snatch one of my favorite Brad
Pitt
maybe now second this will be number one
well what entices you to take a script
or a story and bring it to the big
screen um the money the money right so
if if there is a script that's
unauthorized biopic if there's a slew of
them happening right now is that
something that people can bring as a
director do you bring it to a film i I
can only be get excited by things I can
get excited by it and really I think
that takes place unconsciously so
someone when King Arthur it depends when
you going to catch me but it was King
off and I've just seen a commercial or
some incarnation in this genre you go
all this bits about that quite like and
I think I could do I could do a job on
that so that's really what happens so by
the time this came out a few people have
been told about King Arthur I was a big
fan of King Arthur I saw a couple of
things I went oh right because you that
that that that and create the tone then
we're off to the races and I think into
a job with that